Well, let's see. I have a right triangle here.
I need to know now how can I figure out what this width is?
Well, the side I know is the opposite side.
The side I want to know is this one here--the width.
Now, that's the adjacent side to this angle. It's not the hypotenuse.
Okay, so which trig function relates opposite and adjacent?
Well, that's the tangent.
So, I'm going to be using the tangent of this angle.
I'm going to calculate that, because I know that it has to equal the opposite side
over the adjacent side, which is the width.
Okay, not so bad.
Now I have to solve this for width, which means I have to bring this over here
and put this guy down there, which gives me width equals 25 m/tan(1.3°).
When I plug that in, I like to use Google's calculator,
I get a length of 1100 meters.
Now, this is really an incredible tool.
We use basic trigonometry to make a real calculation.
This is truly how you could have calculated the width of the mouth of the bay of Syracuse. Good work.